[Música]
y ya lo decíamos en directo vamos a
Ecuador para conocer el caso de la
exministra de Obras Públicas María de
los Ángeles Duarte pesantes funcionaria
durante el gobierno de Rafael Correa
Este martes se conoció que se presentó
en la embajada de Argentina en Caracas
tras abandonar la sede diplomática de
Argentina en Quito esto Pese a que el
gobierno de Guillermo lasso le había
prohibido la salida del país de hecho no
le había dado el salvoconducto que se
necesita para abandonar territorio
ecuatoriano conectamos con Gustavo
Ortega corresponsal de France 24 en
Ecuador Gustavo A qué se debe esta
salida del ex ministra y Qué se sabe de
su salida territorio ecuatoriano pese a
no tener el salvoconducto de las
autoridades
Sí muy buenas noches la ex ministra de
Rafael correa de transporte de Obras
Públicas María de los Ángeles duartes ha
escapado de la delegación diplomática de
Argentina en Ecuador así lo ha
notificado el canciller argentino cuando
el día de hoy se comunicó con su
homólogo Ecuatoriano para informarle que
había escapado de la delegación
Argentina y a partir de ahí fue el punto
de quiebre que ha venido tensionando
estas relaciones entre Argentina y
Ecuador A qué se debe bueno se refiere a
luego de que la jueza Daniela Camacho
emitiera su tenencia relacionada al caso
soborno un caso de corrupción que
involucraba no solo a María de los
Ángeles Duarte sino a otros 14
funcionarios en un caso una red de
corrupción de el cual consistía en
entregar coimas al partido de Alianza
país a cambio de contratos durante la
gestión de Rafael Correa también está
involucrada y sentenciada a ocho años
María de los Ángeles Duarte
posteriormente tal y como tú introducido
el gobierno de Ecuador no dio el
salvoconducto para que María de los
Ángeles Duarte abandonara el país y
saliera de manera segura de la
delegación Argentina en este país ella
se había
refugiado en la embajada de Argentina en
Ecuador Argentina había dicho que lo
había recibido de manera humanitaria y
la había otorgado inclusive el asilo
diplomático pero Ecuador se negaba a
ofrecerle este salvoconducto para que
saliera del país posteriormente entonces
Ella salió del país ha sido también el
gobierno argentino quien ha declarado
que María de los Ángeles Duarte ha
llegado a su delegación en Caracas y la
ha atendido pero no ha dado detalles de
cómo llegó y si llevó así a su hijo
menor de edad que tiene una ciudadanía
Argentina Bueno y qué reacciones se han
producido en torno a este caso Ya esta
llegada a Caracas
bueno las principales reacciones han
sido este quiebre entre las relaciones
de ambos países el Ecuador ha declarado
persona no grata al representante
diplomático argentino en este país y ha
dicho que considera que se han vulnerado
los principios de buena fe entre ambos
países el Ecuador ha emitido continuos
comunicados durante todo el día de hoy
pidiendo información a Argentina para
conocer Cuáles fueron las condiciones
por las cuales María de los Ángeles
duartes abandonó la sede diplomática a
pedido inclusive que Argentina entre las
cámaras de seguridad y los vídeos de la
sede diplomática lo cual Argentina ha
negado esto igual forma también
Argentina ha hecho lo propio ha
convocado a su representante diplomático
y Ecuador también ha llamado a consulta
a su representante diplomático en su
país De igual forma también María de los
Ángeles Duarte ha dicho que Ecuador la
bantería en este país como una rn
política y que a ella la protegía el
derecho de
su salvoconducto y el asilo político